fontrell antonio baines also known as
nuke bizzle
is accused of scheming the unemployment
system federal prosecutors point to this
music video
on youtube where they say baines brags
about getting rich by committing fraud
the song's title edd that's california's
employment
development department listen to the
lyrics
investigators say they found 92
unemployment debit cards pre-loaded with
more than 1.2 million
dollars baines and his co-schemers
withdrew more than
700 thousand including in las vegas
and they also spent money on merchandise
and services
the debit cards were issued to people
other than them including identity theft
victims
and they used addresses baines had
access to in beverly hills and koreatown
according to the department of justice
this criminal complaint states 74 claims
were filed for one address
18 for another while the memphis
tennessee native lived in the hollywood
hills
unemployment so sweet we had 1.5 federal
prosecutors say baines was arrested on
september 23 by metro police in las
vegas after he was stopped for speeding
in a cadillac escalade
they say he had eight debit cards on him
with other people's names on them
he faces three felony charges with a
maximum sentence of 22 years if
convicted
that money prosecutors say he stole was
set aside through the cares act
and it should have gone to people who
lost their jobs during the kovit 19
pandemic
vanessa murphy 8 news now